Imagine that you’re in charge of sending
a culture-bearing probe off into space; one
capable of carrying a single example of 20th
Century art.
What would you pick to represent us in the
cosmos?
Some great novel, perhaps?
Or would you pick a slender volume based on
a radio show?
A volume emblazoned with the words DON’T
PANIC; a volume that contains everything from
the precise reason you should always carry
a towel, to how to mix the most-powerful drink
in the universe?
We’re talking, of course, about the Hitchhiker’s
Guide to the Galaxy, perhaps one of the most-unique
pieces of sci-fi ever written.
And the author behind the book we here at
Biographics would send as our emissary to
the stars?
Douglas Adams.
Born in the 1950s, Adams was the product of
a post-war Britain exploding with creativity.
It was the era of the Beatles and Pink Floyd,
of Monty Python, and Doctor Who.
Yet even in this intensely vibrant age, Adams
still managed to dream up a universe so unique
it has arguably never been equalled.
In the video today, we’re thumbing a ride
into the past to explore the life of the man
behind a literary legend.
Mostly Harmless
Far out in the uncharted backwaters of the
unfashionable end of the western spiral arm
of the Galaxy lies a small unregarded yellow
sun.
It was on a planet orbiting this unregarded
sun, in the year 1952, that Douglas Noel Adams
was born.
Later in life, Adams liked to joke that he
was the first DNA in Cambridge, having been
born there several months before Watson and
Crick discovered the far more famous version.
But aside from raising a smile, that gag may
have also served to hide painful memories.
The family Douglas Adams was born into was
both deeply eccentric, and deeply fractured.
A lot of this fracturing came courtesy of
the boy’s father, Christopher Douglas Adams.
A bombastic giant of a man with a personality
the size of Canada, Christopher was a man
who loved booze, cars, and women.
You’ll notice that’s women, plural, not
woman, singular, which may be why the Adams
household fairly radiated misery.
Before Adams was even five, his parents had
divorced, and he’d gone to live with his
mother’s parents.
Well, make that “her parents and their animals.”
Adams’s maternal grandmother was an animal
lover par excellence, and the house was overrun
with stray dogs, stray cats, stray badgers,
and anything else that might conceivably eat
your food and poop everywhere.
Perhaps it was due to the endless clamor in
the house, but Adams became so introverted
at school that his teachers thought him “mentally
subnormal”.
But while the boy may have had a weird, unhappy
childhood, he never suffered financially.
Not long after ditching his family, Christopher
Adams had managed to seduce an incredibly
wealthy widow who paid for Adams to have a
private education.
Thus it was that, aged 11, the boy was dispatched
to the elite Brentwood boarding school.
For Adams, Brentwood was the first time he
ever felt his oddness was appreciated.
Not yet 12, Adams was already a 6ft giant,
and would continue to grow until he hit 6ft5.
On top of that, he’d inherited both his
father’s gigantic personality and his gigantic
nose, making him both a natural performer
and instantly recognizable.
This translated easily into performing in
school plays, where Adams became renowned
for his bizarre sense of humor.
Not that it was really his sense of humor.
In 1969, the first season of Monty Python’s
Flying Circus had exploded the BBC like a
particularly silly stick of dynamite.
Like everyone else his age, Adams had fallen
in love with the troupe.
But while most kids wanted to watch the Pythons,
Adams wanted to be them.
As he later commented:
"I wanted to be John Cleese.
It took me some time to realise that the job
was taken."
But it wasn’t just Monty Python that had
gripped Adams’s imagination.
Britain in 1969 was in the midst of a full-blown
cultural explosion.
There was Python’s comedy, the Beatles’
music, Doctor Who’s sci-fi wanderings.
With a talent as distinct as Adams’s, it’s
tempting to think he just sprang from nowhere.
But no, his was a sense of humor born from
a particular moment in British history.
But while all the ingredients for his greatest
work were in the air in the 1960s, they only
coalesced together thanks to pure chance.
In the summer of 1971, Adams was traveling
around Europe between finishing at Brentwood
and starting at Cambridge University.
As the legend goes, he found himself at some
point lying dead drunk in a field in Austria,
contemplating alternately his Hitch-Hiker’s
Guide to Europe and the stars spinning above
him.
Just before he lost consciousness, the drunken
teenager had a thought that would change his
life.
He decided that someone should write a hitchhiker’s
guide not to another continent…
...but to the galaxy.
The Python Years
If it was overindulgence in alcohol that gave
Adams his great idea, it was likely also alcohol
that stopped him from doing anything with
it.
By 1974, Adams had graduated Cambridge after
student years in which he did heroically little
work and heroically huge amounts of drinking.
Now he was living in London, still drinking
heroic amounts, but doing nothing except writing
the odd sketch the BBC would immediately reject.
But while the boozy London life was keeping
Adams from his art, it was also gonna give
him his bug break.
That same year, Adams was introduced to Graham
Chapman.
If that name sounds familiar, it’s because
Chapman was the fabled straight man of Monty
Python - straight in the comedic sense, as
Chapman was openly gay.
He was also a man who liked to drink, and
liked others who liked to drink.
And in Adams, he seemed to have finally found
the perfect drinking buddy.
Throughout the year, the two met up to imbibe
indescribable quantities of alcohol.
The more often they met, the more Chapman
became convinced Adams had a talent for sketch
comedy.
So he gave him a spot on the biggest sketch
show on Earth.
On December 5, 1974, Douglas Adams became
one of only two non-members to have ever written
for Monty Python.
His sketch, Patient Abuse, features Chapman
as a doctor who forces a heavily-bleeding
Terry Jones to fill out endless inane forms
before he’ll give him any treatment.
It’s a classic Adams riff on bureaucracy,
albeit one tooled to Python’s specific brand
of humor.
It was also successful enough that Chapman
asked Adams to keep writing with him after
Python ended.
In 1975, the two made a pilot for a sketch
show called Out of the Trees.
We don’t need to go into Trees too much.
Only one episode was ever made and, as Adams
once said, it “had some good bits, but it
wasn’t really that good.”
Still, it’s worth noting the one big sketch
Adams contributed.
At the end of the episode, a young couple
pick a flower off a bush.
This causes a chain reaction of events which
begins with the police being called out, progresses
to the whole of Europe going to war, and ends
with the complete destruction of the world.
From that point on, Armageddon would be a
subject that obsessed the young writer.
When Out of the Trees failed, Chapman ditched
his new writing partner, drifting back to
Python’s surreal embrace.
Although Adams would contribute a couple of
one liners to Monty Python and the Holy Grail,
that was really it for his sketch writing
career.
Depressed, Adams returned to his mum’s house.
Over the next year, 1976, he continued to
try his hand at writing and performing, but
it all went nowhere.
There was the sketch show he went on tour
with, which ran at two hours, but only contained
one good gag.
There was the pilot series he wrote with a
friend, about a pair of astronomers who discover
the world is about to be destroyed to make
way for an interstellar advertising sign,
that the BBC refused to touch.
There was even a spec script he sent to the
Doctor Who production office, one about the
Doctor becoming trapped on a ship crewed entirely
by the useless people of society.
But while the Doctor Who team liked the idea,
they didn’t pick it up.
Come Christmas, 1976, Adams was trapped at
his mum’s place, his career dead in the
water, and on the verge of giving up.
At that moment, it must’ve seen to him like
1977 would bring nothing but more disappointment,
more bad news.
Well, buckle up, because Adams is about to
be proven wrong.
The next twelve months were gonna hit the
young man like a black ship diving into the
heart of a sun.
Hitchhiking the Galaxy
On a dismal February day in 1977, Adams made
a trip to London to have lunch with the BBC’s
light entertainment producer.
It had been over a month since Adams’s depressing
Christmas, and paid writing work was still
out of reach.
That all changed that fateful day.
As the two ate, the producer happened to mention
that he wanted a sci-fi comedy series for
Radio 4.
He wondered aloud if Adams might like to try
his hand at a pilot episode?
And just like that, Adams was a writer again.
Adams’ initial pitch was The Ends of the
Earth, a six-part comedy in which every episode
would end with the Earth blowing up.
But as he was writing the pilot - in which
Earth is demolished to make way for a hyperspace
bypass - Adams decided he needed to give his
alien character, Ford Prefect, a job.
At last, that idea he’d had long ago lying
drunk in a field in Austria came back to him.
Ford Prefect would be a researcher for the
Hitchhiker’s Guide to the Galaxy.
From that moment, the concept of Ends of the
Earth went out the window, replaced by a series
about Ford Prefect, the Guide he was researching,
and his human pal Arthur Dent.
By March, the pilot episode for The Hitchhiker’s
Guide to the Galaxy was ready to go.
The BBC gave it the green light.
That June, the cast assembled in London to
record the episode.
It didn’t take long, and that should’ve
been that.
But something had changed in Douglas Adams,
a zeal had come over him since he’d decided
what his radio show was gonna be about.
No longer did Adams simply want to make a
radio comedy.
He wanted to make something unlike anything
anyone had ever heard before.
A sci-fi show with production levels Pink
Floyd would envy.
For the rest of that summer, Adams and his
producer tinkered away in the booth, creating
the sci-fi soundscape for their show.
They spent as long on single sound effects
as some radio shows did on an entire series.
But it was worth it.
By fall, the pilot was being circulated around
the BBC.
Everyone loved it.
As winter approached, Adams was called in
to two very important meetings.
The first was with the Doctor Who team, who’d
heard his pilot and now wanted him to write
a four-part episode.
The second was with Radio 4.
They wanted to commission a full series of
Hitchhiker’s.
Naturally, Adams said yes to both of them.
This would become a pattern in Adams’s life:
taking on so much work he became trapped in
permanent panic mode, barely able to finish
by the deadline.
In the future, this would become a crippling
problem that severely limited his output.
But in 1977, Adams was still young, and still
just able to get things done.
Although it was touch and go.
The biggest problem was that, while Adams
had a tone and ideas for Hitchhiker’s, he
didn’t have a story.
So inventing a plot on the fly became harder
and harder.
Things got so bad that Adams would be forced
to finish episodes inside the booth as the
cast were recording around him.
When that didn’t work, he had to bring in
his friends to finish them for him.
Still, finish them he did.
At 10:30pm on 8 March, 1978, the first episode
of Hitchhiker’s Guide to the Galaxy was
broadcast on Radio 4.
As it went out, Adams presumably clutched
his towel and hoped it would be successful.
But even in his wildest fantasies, he couldn’t
have forseen how successful it would become.
Doctor Who
and
the Writer of Death
Adams would later say of Hitchhiker’s sudden
success that "It was like being helicoptered
to the top of Mount Everest.
Or having an orgasm without the foreplay."
People loved it.
Major newspapers raved about it.
People flooded the Post Office with letters
addressed to the Guide itself.
If you’re new to the work of Douglas Adams,
you may be wondering what made people so obsessed
with Hitchhiker’s.
Here was a show in which the basic plot was
that the Earth was destroyed, and now the
alien guidebook researcher Ford and his human
friend Arthur were stuck traipsing around
the galaxy.
But the genius of Hitchhiker’s doesn’t
lie in the plot, but in the comic concepts
the show carelessly threw out by the dozens,
each clever enough to make a series in its
own right.
There’s the supercomputer Deep Thought,
which spends centuries calculating the meaning
of “life, the universe, and everything,”
only to solemnly report that the answer is
42.
There’s the android Marvin, who is created
with a brain so big he can conceive of the
futility of his existence and so spends the
series in a state of terminal depression.
There are time travelling Chesterfield sofas;
a bowl of petunias that’s last thought before
plummeting out of space and shattering on
a planet is “oh no, not again”; and a
spaceship crewed entirely by the most useless
members of society.
Yep, that last one is the same idea Adams
pitched to Doctor Who.
Cannibalizing his own work would soon become
a core part of Adams’ method.
By April, 1978, Hitchhiker’s was a British
sensation.
A book was swiftly commissioned for Adams
to write, along with a second radio series.
It was enough work for any aspiring writer.
But Adams wasn’t just any aspiring writer.
He was a madman with an attraction to impossible
workloads.
Which may be why Adams agreed to also take
on the job of script editing Doctor Who.
Although it’s overshadowed by Hitchhiker’s,
Adams’ year at Doctor Who is semi-legendary.
Adams took on the job out of a fondness of
the show, and a mistaken belief that it wouldn’t
be too demanding.
Instead he found himself working on a show
where veteran writers would write a four page
treatment for a four part serial, hand it
to the script editor and tell him to turn
it into two hours of television.
This meant Adams doing the work not only of
ten people, but also handling rewrites on
top of that.
But it also meant a year of Doctor Who filled
with Hitchhiker’s-style inspiration.
The highlight of this was City of Death, a
four part story set in Paris where the Doctor
steals the Mona Lisa, meets Leonardo da Vinci,
shares a scene with John Cleese, and accidentally
creates all life on Earth.
It’s a fun, joyful, hilarious bit of TV,
and it was written in a single, panic-and-alcohol
fueled weekend when the original writer dropped
out at the last second, leaving Adams to pick
up the pieces.
Incredible as City of Death was, though, it
severely restricted Adams’ time for working
on Hitchhiker’s.
By early 1979, Adams was in a catastrophic
state of procrastination on the book adaptation,
with almost nothing written.
Finally, as the deadline swept by, his editor
just told him to finish whatever page he was
on and hand the damn thing over.
With a third of the original season still
unadapted, Adams meekly complied.
Book one of the Hitchhiker’s trilogy was
published in September, 1979.
It immediately shot to the top of the bestseller
lists.
Aged only 27, Adams was now at the head of
a bona fide phenomenon.
Now all he needed to do was make sure it didn’t
go to his head.
God and Nature
The 1980s began in a whirlwind of success
for Adams.
As the rest of Britain embraced the Thatcher
era - reluctantly or otherwise - Hitchhiker’s
season two went out on radio, followed by
the second book, The Restaurant at the End
of the Universe, and then a BAFTA-winning
BBC TV adaptation.
With all this exposure came what every struggling
writer always craves.
Money.
Lots and lots of money.
By 1981, Adams was a seriously wealthy guy.
He began channeling his father’s spirit,
blowing cash on cars, girls, meals, music,
and computers.
Yes, computers.
One of the reasons companies like Google program
Hitchhiker’s easter eggs into their search
engine is because Adams was a hugely influential
writer on technology.
He was one of the first to grasp what the
coming information age would mean, and toured
the US giving witty, knowledgeable lectures
on the subject.
But while this won him legions of fans in
Silicon Valley, writing was still his bread
and butter.
And Adams was starting to find it harder and
harder.
When the time came to write the third Hitchhiker’s
book, Adams simply cannibalized one of his
old, unproduced scripts for Doctor Who.
And so it was that Doctor Who and the Krikket
Men became Life, the Universe and Everything.
By the time the fourth book in the increasingly
inaccurately-named trilogy came out, in 1984,
Adams could barely stand to be with his own
creation.
“To be honest, I really shouldn't have written
[it],” he later said, “and I felt that
when I was writing it.
I did the best I could, but it wasn't, you
know, really from the heart.”
But even as his chronic procrastination began
to turn into fully-fledged writer’s block,
Adams’s luck kept right on going.
At the start of the decade, he met his future
wife, Jane Elizabeth Belson.
He also met an absurd number of famous people.
Before long, Adams and Belsons’s house in
Ilsington was throwing parties where you could
bump into anyone from John Cleese, to Stephen
Fry, to Richard Dawkins.
Yes, that Richard Dawkins.
Adams described himself as a “radical atheist,”
and was naturally besties with the scientist.
But perhaps the coolest people Adams befriended
were Pink Floyd.
There are legends that, halfway through his
parties, Adams would hand out guitars, and
treat the crowd to an impromptu Pink Floyd
gig.
But even as Adams’ star rose, he was beginning
to discover just how ephemeral this shiny
world was.
In 1985, Adams was sent alongside zoologist
Mark Carwardine to Madagascar to write an
article about endangered animals for the Observer.
The two hit it off and, a couple of years
later, did a radio series together about endangered
species.
It was a show that would change Adams’ life.
The show and it’s book Last Chance to See
was Adams’ personal wake-up call to the
damage humans were doing to their environment.
In the aftermath, he would become one of the
earliest, loudest voices on conservation and
the dangers posed by habitat destruction.
Still, the 1980s ended on a relatively good
note.
Adams managed to get over his writer’s block
long enough to write two Dirk Gently detective
stories (one of which, again, cannibalized
his old Doctor Who scripts) and, in 1991,
finally married Jane Elizabeth Belson.
At the start of the 90s, Adams was in his
late thirties, world famous, rich, and married
to the woman of his dreams.
If this kept up, who knew what the rest of
his life would be like?
Unfortunately, we here in the future already
know the tragic answer.
Douglas Adams may have not yet been forty…
…but he was already entering the final decade
of his life.
So Long, and Thanks for All the Fish
The last ten years of Adams’ life dawned
with the writer in a bleak place.
After nearly seven years, he’d agreed to
write the fifth Hitchhiker’s book, on the
understanding that it would be the last.
Even so, his writer’s block crippled him.
There would be nothing, for weeks on end.
Nothing but Adams locked away in hotels by
his grim-faced editor, staring at the ceiling.
We’ve heard tales that the publisher hired
a fleet of writers to sit downstairs, churning
out chapters based on Adams’ outline, until
Adams was finally roused to work by the thought
of all these other writers doing his book
wrong.
Mostly Harmless was released in 1992.
It was, without a doubt, the bleakest thing
Adams ever wrote, with a downer ending that
leaves a nasty taste in the mouth.
Much later, Adams would claim he’d been
seriously depressed while writing it.
It really shows.
Still, life moves fast and, within a couple
of years of the gloomy conclusion of Hitchhiker’s,
Adams seemed to be living life to the full
again.
For his 42nd birthday in 1994, for example,
he was invited onstage by Pink Floyd to play
a gig with them.
Later that same year, his daughter, Polly
Jane Rocket Adams, was born.
By the 21st Century, Adams was lecturing in
Silicon Valley, developing video games with
his production company, and working on turning
Hitchhiker’s into a Hollywood movie.
He’d even started writing again, tentatively
putting together ten chapters of a third Dirk
Gently book that he thought might even become
the sixth Hitchhiker’s book.
And then it happened.
The moment.
The moment as shocking to his fandom as the
sight of a Vogon Constructor Fleet hanging
in the air in much the same way that bricks
don't.
On May 11, 2001, Douglas Adams suffered a
massive heart attack at his local gym.
At the time he died, he wasn’t even 50.
In the wake of Adams’ death, tributes poured
in from around the world.
This wasn’t just the regular sadness we
feel when someone passes away.
This was a keenly felt pain, almost personal
- like that felt when John Lennon or David
Bowie died.
As Stephen Fry later noted, Hitchhiker’s
had been sci-fi on a human scale.
It resonated with people, made it feel like
Adams was talking to them and them alone.
And that may be why his death devastated so
many people.
But what should we today make of Douglas Adams?
What should we make of the man who wrote a
handful of slim, comic volumes before vanishing
into the abyss?
Well, it depends on your perspective.
Right now, it’s still too early to tell
what Adams’s long term impact on fiction
will be.
While he has endless admirers, there’s a
sense that his work was maybe too unique,
a dead end for any writer who doesn’t happen
to be a comic genius.
On the other hand, Adams’ influence is already
everywhere.
We mentioned earlier that Adams was an early
adopter - of environmentalism, of computers,
of ideas - and part of his charm was his ability
to take those ideas and explain them simply,
in ways that still impact the ways his readers
think.
As Neil Gaiman said in 2015:
“I think perhaps what Douglas was, was a
futurologist, or an explainer.
One day maybe we’ll realise that the most
important job there is, is someone who can
explain the world to itself in ways the world
can’t forget.”
The continents may grow old and die, the world
may be demolished to make way for a hyperspace
bypass, but somewhere, out there in the cosmos,
some lifeform will always be sat in a restaurant
at the end of the universe, reading in wide-eyed
wonder as Douglas Adams explains the world
to it.
And that lifeform will be smiling.